hello everyone and welcome back to some
rapid action un leaches yesterday we won
a fairly smooth game uh with the wi
pieces but don't expect every game to be
like that that was um pretty much one
one in 100 so let's see how well we do
today and hopefully you guys will be
able to learn something from this we're
continuing with 10 minutes per player uh
only accepting uh high rated opponents
so at get some good chessing and okay we
got a game but our opponent aborted
probably because we are not um rated
high enough as he is 2400 so we will go
for another one uh so yeah we we'll see
if the next opponent will be interested
in playing
us yeah it's okay it's a lot to invest
maybe 20 minutes to play against um 200
points low rated player but then again
you know chances are that you will win
so I don't know it's a you know give or
take probably he also wants to play
against um uh higher rated opponents
uh so we'll see and yeah we got the
white pieces in last one so I imagine I
mean it doesn't matter sometimes you get
white sometimes you get black uh and our
opponent is uh elban from Turkey rated
2441 okay so a very nice rating Let's uh
uh do our best okay he goes for D4 and I
usually go for Knight to F6 so I'm going
to stick to that uh in my younger days I
was um countering with D4 and he goes
for Bishop to G5 it's the trosi attack
and I know zero theory on this other
than you can attack the bishop with
Knight to E4 so I'm going to play that
and we'll see where where the game takes
me and uh yeah I'm B mostly relying on
my sense of principles here so okay I
wasted um a move with the Knight so
breaking some opening principles here
but he will also have to waste a move
with the bishop uh or maybe he won't
yeah he he's going to play H4 okay so
it's some sort of a force line that uh
he wants me to uh invest in so I'm not
sure how to go about this but he does
have a central D Pawn up the board I'm
going to challenge it with my uh with my
C Pawn Yeah he goes for uh the advanced
uh and now we have to figure out how to
go about this I might capture and just
play E5 sort of to either get a very
nice Center or um to pressure that G5
Pawn checking doesn't really do all that
much I have to figure out how to get my
pieces into the game or maybe I can even
just um maybe I can even just play G6
and faneto my Bishop uh I do have D4
covered so I don't have to be worried
about a double attack so let's try
that let's try that okay so he goes
after my
knight
okay can we give can we play Bishop G7
sort of give a knight to go for The
Rook does appear to be a bit greedy but
uh
uh and then maybe some D6 action yeah
looks looks fairly scary maybe I can
play F5
here maybe I can play F5 here I'm not
really sure he wants to play a move like
F3 but
okay I trust him okay so that's the
that's the trick that's the
trick that's the trick
okay
H that's very
interesting yeah very
interesting and then he's going to
capture okay I mean we don't really lose
all that much I'm
guessing yeah we're going to go Bishop
G7 uh he does Capt on C5 we're going to
Capt on G5 and okay he did mess up my
Pawn structure and uh yeah okay he he is
sort of dictating the tone of the battle
here with this forc line but on the
other hand he really didn't get that
much development in h he'll probably
develop the Knight here Castle Queen
side so I don't know if capturing the C
Pawn is the way to go all right so uh
since I still cannot capture my G Pawn
will be hanging now the question is do I
Castle here do we Castle here or do we
play D6 that's the
question uh but I'm pretty sure will
Castle uh we will allow him to capture
here as now he kind of has to capture
and then he will probably take on C5 and
he claims that this is good for
him or yeah H D6 probably was the way to
go I I completely missed Queen H3 if
that's a move if Queen H3 is a move I I
might be in some trouble
here now he doesn't go for Queen H3 it's
very
interesting very interesting indeed
huh I'm going to capture with the
bishop but then he has
E5 capture with the bishop he has E5 if
I capture with the pawn then he has
Queen H3 if I capture with the bishop
Queen H3 then I can maybe play Rook F7
but no we're going to capture with the
bishop and if he plays E5 we're going to
have to play Bishop all the way back to
h8 so we can play Rook F7 if he goes
Queen H3 so Queen H3 now I don't think
is all that
impressive
but yeah he does have me somewhat tied
down here yeah I'm very interested to
see how how this will turn out and I
will have serious issues developing here
maybe really not
sure yeah maybe I'm just uh maybe I'm
just putting too much faith in this
queen H3 move maybe it's really
nothing yeah so okay so obviously we
want to develop here if we play this
Pawn he'll okay he can't play push that
pawn so we're just going to play like
like this now Knight G5 can be met with
Bishop
captures yeah as the light Square Bishop
opened up yeah this is a this is a
complete mess yeah this is just one huge
complete
mess yeah okay fair fair that's
fair uh yeah the bishop here is very
nice
although although how nice is it really
that is the
question
H let's play B5
here let's play B5 I don't like the
bishop on this diagonal not one
bit and now let's get our Queen into the
game it's not a lot but it does get the
queen into the game okay so he will play
kn Knight
here I like that and now I'm already
considering some Rook captures on F3
Bishop captures on E5 business but not
just
yet not just
yet yeah let's attack the Knight
first let's attack the Knight
first yeah I mean uh the Knight A3
defending the bishop is nice but now the
Knight can't really move and the Knight
would really love to come to C4 so first
he has to move the bishop so he gets the
C4 Square for his
Knight yeah no I'm I'm of course I'm
guessing that his position is better
here due to the open semiopen H file he
does have a beautiful Center here but uh
so far tactically I'm not uh I'm not
seeing it and I will be able to capture
here at some point uh not sure if I want
to do that simply because I really want
to have my uh H3 Square covered by the
bishop Bop uh but since he was not
interested in it maybe it's really not
all that impressive and I'm going to if
he moves the bishop now which probably
is the way to
go yeah sort of uh if he doesn't do
anything yeah even a move like Bishop to
E2 is a move
here because then maybe if I trade he
has the in between Knight C4 which could
be
relevant yeah I don't know he's also
considering a whole lot of stuff here as
uh he is wasting
time um but yeah once he castles Queen
side and that is most likely what is to
happen here uh I do have to be careful
of him for example doubling Rook Rooks
on the H file but as soon as he does
that then once once uh we we capture
here and we might even capture with the
Rook I don't know not right now it
depends on the position we might capture
here we're opening up this diagonal then
our Queen Bishop combo becomes very
strong yeah I don't know uh okay so
he uh defends the bishop so he can play
Knight to C4 as we expected and uh yeah
Knight to C4 is very nice now if I
capture yeah that's uh a nice move it's
a nice move but and also now yeah he
unpinned here so that's quite
useful uh do I have Bishop captures on
E5 no I don't do I Knight captures and
then C4 attacks the queen
uh opens up
this pretty crazy
stuff
h
or do I just trade with with Pawn A6
that is the question or do I have Bishop
captures on E5 Knight C C4 attacks the
queen uh but then okay he df2 point is
hanging he can play something like Queen
to B3 yeah it doesn't look like uh it
look it doesn't look like there's really
anything
there nah I think I have to settle for
this it's not uh nothing spectacular but
I don't see anything
better yeah and once we trade Queens
we're going to capture on F3 pick up D5
pawn and I think we got we got an okay
position here it's not uh not great but
it's okay he will have to deal with the
B tons probably something like Knight to
C3 or maybe just Knight C4 yeah I will
attack my bishop and guard the pawn even
that's even that's
possible yeah so now the question is uh
what to play
does he have Queen A4 that's also a very
interesting question so if I capture he
can take the
Rook yeah that's very
interesting but if he does that nah
that's silly I'm I'm talking nonsense
yeah okay so he just goes for that we're
going to trade here we're going to trade
here we're just going to trade
everywhere capture
captures yeah he goes Knight
here and we go back I mean not much to
to be done about all this business here
yeah we go back Bishop G7 maybe maybe
some other square but uh yeah
G7 as good as any and now if I can get
my knight into the game and sort of uh
sort of um make my E7 Pawn either useful
or not not like a huge Target I also
should be okay here yeah material is
equal yeah it's a pretty pretty crazy
position
prettyy crazy
position am I interested in trading the
Knight also is one of the questions yeah
okay so he goes for that yeah we're
going to go Here Also regarding
B6 and
[Music]
uh yeah but it's not uh it's not much
yeah this is a permanent weakness here
that we can sort of uh yeah something
like if if we get the Rooks into game
maybe something like Bishop to F6 we
play H5 so he cannot Advance the G pawn
and kick away our Bishop actually could
be pretty safe SO trading the knights
here I think is what I want to
do uh but if I if I just attack it yeah
he's just going to play Knight to
B6 yeah it's
uh he's going to go Knight to B6 and
then if I play Rook B1 Rook B8 um he
might even capture on A6 and I could
could capture here but I'm not
interested in trading this Pawn for a
doubled B Pawn that's not uh that's not
good
chess yeah okay so he's kind of forcing
me to do it but no he also yeah he wants
me to play this and then he's going to
check me and I have to go here and then
then I really like his
position uh so yeah this is a this is a
great
move this is a great move by by
him yeah really like that
really like
that yeah okay but I've got nothing
better I've got nothing better I have to
allow
it um and then he might even have a no
he doesn't have this because I can
always block the the next Rook check
with Bishop to H6 and he will take the
bishop but I have King G7 so for the
moment he doesn't have it but it's uh he
almost has it he he almost has
it yeah now F4 could be
I don't think yeah he first wants to
play Knight B6 and then once I no he's
going to go Knight here it's very
interesting that's a most interesting
move yeah now he can do it because I
don't have a threat of any
sort how to get this bishop out of
here yeah I have to go back I have to go
back I have to go back now he could stop
this with pon4 but I'm going to put my
knight here
then yeah we can't really okay so he
doesn't he doesn't want to stop that
very interesting okay so let's just
attack the bishop also we have support
for H7 if he wants the double Rooks here
oh no he he will just double
Rooks very interesting
that is most
interesting very very nice lovely lovely
even
I have to play H5 here have no other
option and while
G4 maybe is a
move I don't know if G4 is a move like
G4 maybe I have Knight here with some
Knight checking action and then if he
even if he captures even if he captures
I can always play G5 and close the H
file maybe that's also yeah okay so he
goes here uh what is
this he he's he he says he can even do
this wow that's very impressive that's
very
impressive h
that is very
good yeah and if I play this he's just
going to capture this is very good stuff
but I can play this I can play
this now if he attacks with the Knight
then the bishop hangs so the bishop
can't really remain there for a very
long time as now the doubling of the
Rooks on the f file can happen and if
you ever play this I can I can just
capture it if you go go yeah now F4 yeah
he's going to play G4 now
okay that's
fair really nice really
nice he's really squeezing me
here yeah really squeezing me
here this this is
painful
it's very
painful yeah he sees everything he sees
absolutely everything let's double
up no other move we can
make and if he plays we're going to play
G5 no okay let's go
here now he has to take I'm going to
play G5 he's uh I would say he's winning
uh or maybe he's been winning for the
entire game
uh so we'll
see yeah very very tricky stuff
here now he has to worry about this okay
so he stops
that
um let's go
here I've got nothing
better I've got nothing
better and the minute on the clock
yeah yeah okay we have to we have to go
for this not nothing
better I either have some tricks or I
don't
yeah okay so he goes here we're going to
go after his Rook of
course now this is very strong now this
is very strong now yeah perhaps that
wasn't the way to
go
H yep that's uh that's the spot yeah
we're going to we're going to play this
as
yeah pretty much blundered
it uh but no it's not that I blunder the
move it's just that the the pressure was
overwhelming throughout the entire game
and uh yeah in the end it it worked out
well for him yeah of course he's going
to play that we can give one check let's
check here capture
here
uh
yeah maybe maybe it's still possible to
save this but
uh yeah trading Rooks of course uh wins
him the game that uh without without a
question yeah he'll just push the pawn
and I'm completely tied up
here yeah let's go
here let's go after the pawn let's go
after the G
Pawn I can even win a pawn but uh he's
just up too much material it doesn't uh
it's not not very relevant yeah okay
we're going to go after this
Pawn
um I'm going to go
here yeah I can't really trade because
if I trade he's just
winning yeah there we go let's go here
sort of cover this Square not much let's
go here take the pawn he's going to
trade and push the B Pawn no he's not
let's go back let's go here yeah that's
a okay now he's just
winning yeah okay I tried to trick him a
little bit but he's not only precise but
also fast yeah so good game uh Alban
from Turkey uh let's see let's see what
uh what we did here that was uh that was
very very wrong so okay we went for this
line of the trosi he played H4 I've seen
it it's uh obviously called the Raptor
variation of the trpovski I played C5
okay okay seems you can play it uh he
played D5 I played uh G6 okay the queen
D3 I captured here yeah obviously on
Queen D3 Bishop G7 is the way to go the
move that we discussed yeah it's sort of
the forced line that I don't know I
didn't know to play a D6 and then what I
capture and what if he captures I just
play Queen B6 and I'm winning wow okay
uh yeah but still like
H5 and then Knight to C6 yeah okay it's
a line that if you want to play if
someone plays the trosi against you you
have to know it uh Bishop GC is 7 this
Force line after after this Knight
captures and queen C3 I played F6 he
captured I play Bishop G7 so yeah it's
perfect fine okay but not castling here
D6 is the way to go I castled yeah and
now Queen to H3 is the move that I was
afraid of but he didn't play
it uh and again he didn't play it yeah I
guess he missed Queen to H3 on both of
those
occasions D6 and now B5 yeah uh is the
move I played sort of Knight to D7 was
the way to get back into the game
because he kind of uh got himself all
all worked up over this um E5 Pawn but I
thought thought yeah I thought I have to
give up a little bit of material to get
back into the game yeah now A6 and now
this is uh okay not trading Queens yeah
just Knight D7 again okay yeah yeah
basically yeah if you consider some
principles it's a free developing move
uh instead of trading the queen and
giving The Rook DH file the D file but
okay I traded and I captured here I was
already down on time so I wanted to win
back my material uh but yeah here I
already started to feel the squeeze
yeah I played this he played this check
Knight here H this is okay so here still
I I should capture on B2 I went for this
knight move instead and that allowed him
F4 but he played this Rook move I played
H5 Bishop to F5 yeah and now again yeah
sort of we we're playing uh a question
mark moves but it's I know a hard
position with a little time on the clock
yeah now King G8 just unpinning is the
way to go yeah because then he cannot
capture because the B Bishop with hangs
yeah so this again gives him the
advantage yeah Knight E5 was the way to
go here so this is still playable yeah
this is 0 Zer Bishop to H6 here I played
Rook
F4 uh sort of still
playable yeah but here capturing with
the pawn is the way to go and I thought
about that but I thought maybe yeah uh
no sorry capturing with the Rook is the
way to go I thought capturing with the
pawn would give me a bit more but now
he's completely winning and he took
advantage of it
yeah very nicely played uh so it's a
tricky line uh if you know it you know
you're you're going to waste way way
less time than I did in the opening but
yeah yeah you you have to know it
obviously it can be played on any level
and my opponent played it played it well
yeah he could have ended the game
basically in the opening he found Queen
to H3 but uh maybe he thought yeah if I
allow if I'm allowing it maybe it
doesn't work because uh even I was able
to convince myself that it doesn't work
because he he didn't play it so yeah uh
nice case of double blind right there
but yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh I enjoyed I enjoyed
playing it but you know I would enjoy it
a lot more if I actually knew some
theory behind that trosi line uh so yeah
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
probably tomorrow with some more rapid
action uh so uh see you
soon